[Music]
what are some of the most common myths
about the Stanford application process
you know I think the myth that I hear
most frequently is that members of the
admissions committee at Stanford have
some magic checklist that each applicant
must fulfill in order to be admitted to
our program I've heard things like I
have to have a GMAT score over 700 or I
need to work in a particular industry to
be admitted or even come from a
particular type of educational
institution and really nothing could be
farther from the truth if you think
about the last few classes that we've
admitted we have students from over 60
different countries we have students
from 160 different educational
institutions and we have students coming
in from I think on average over 300
different work environments before they
come different companies and there's
only 400 students in a class so you can
see in reality we're not admitting
humans for what they've done and who
they are were not admitting people just
because they went to a certain
institution or worked in a certain
industry in fact I was just I think it
was a few weekends ago we're at admitted
students weekend which I know you've
been to ed met weekend and there were
two students I was talking to and one of
them said that both of them said they
almost didn't apply to Stanford I came
this close to not apply and I'm like why
one said he was in a chat room and
somebody told him that all Stanford will
never admit you because of the
institution because the university that
you went to and he was he went to a
state school and in the Midwest and then
another student said the same thing that
happened to her and one of her peers
from work had told her they were talking
about where they wanted to apply that
with her GPA and test scores should
never get into Stanford so luckily for
us both of these students decided that
for themselves whether or not they
should apply and are now going to be
entering this fall so we're really
excited about that I think what's most
important to me is to tell you do not
underestimate your own potential there's
no perfect applicant
there's no checklist that we're looking
at of attributes that we require decide
for yourself whether you're worth the
investment to go through the application
process and what I know from talking to
many many applicants in the past that
you spending the time to know what's
most important to you what you value
what your aspirations are
and then what you've really done in the
accomplishments you've had there's going
to be critical to you at this point in
time and no matter what you do
so we're genuinely excited to learn
about you to learn about how you how
you've actually had impact on your teams
your organization's and your communities
and what you care about so if you have a
story to tell us
you know that we're here and genuinely
ready to and excited to read it